nevada state police still aren't
answering questions about that tragic
accident nearly two weeks ago but the
eight news now i-team is uncovering new
information that's right metro police
detective justin terry was killed after
a beam collapsed on the car he was
driving the i-team's vanessa murphy
obtained new documents which may help
provide insight about what happened
vanessa
yeah we're trying to put the pieces
together here about how this happened
it's a challenge since nevada state
police are not providing answers but we
now have the permits for the company
which owns the truck involved metro
police detective justin terry was
driving near the centennial bowl project
on the morning of june 10 when a
tractor-trailer hit an early warning
beam for a bridge up ahead the beam
collapsed on terry's car and he died at
that scene the 8 news now i-team learned
north las vegas-based western states
contracting is responsible for that
truck according to the nevada department
of transportation the company had 10
ndot issued permits at the time of the
accident
all of them for a truck 15 feet high an
ndot spokesman says the beam is
approximately 15 feet high so you can
see how it didn't make it under the
permits also specify only one piece of
freight is allowed when overweight is
involved a pilot car is required and
there are also
route restrictions without additional
information though it's difficult to
determine whether rules were violated
i'm also waiting to find out if nevada
state police have determined whether
that beam was properly secured back to
you